all right trigger question for the
unsung heroes here we go all right it's
uh it's based around leonard fournette
who had a phenomenal playoff run
first player to score a td in all four
games
of a single post season since who so i
don't even know the answer i'll help you
i'm going to try to let's talk this out
it's got to be a team of course that got
to the super bowl right through the wild
card larry fitzgerald
wow boom good job
way to go i would not have got that one
for sure
well the first thing i thought of is
that 2008
playoff run where he just he just found
a higher calling right yeah and just
went crazy it was kind of a guess but
they were a wild card team that you
remember they were nine and seven yeah
people were saying they didn't belong in
the playoffs and
they went on that tear i just assumed he
scored a touchdown in every game because
he was awesome in every game yeah
all right tyrell davis deb and white go
ahead that's a good one
but they always had buys yeah so no he
had their games in 1997 he did it that
first year they beat the packers
remember they made it as a wild card
team
but sorry go ahead okay uh devin white
yeah
the guy that i would have voted for as
mvp of the game
obviously tom brady with the three
touchdown passes and the tom brady
is going to get it but and i i was
saying this yesterday on pftpm
if football had the equivalent of the
hockey con smythe trophy which goes to
the mvp of the entire postseason it
would be devon white
without question i mean he saved them
against the saints
he lifted the team to a higher level
defensively
to allow them to get past the division
around but but even in the super bowl i
think that
that his performance and everything he
brings to the table and the fact that it
was the defense not the offense that won
that game
for the bucks i'd go devon white yeah i
i think that's hands down the pick
right there there's no doubt yes you
know again
i wish there was a way they could show a
little love to the defensive people
in the super bowl a little bit because
we know it should become such an
offensive quarterback award altogether
but
amazing um best best linebacker in
football either
him or fred warner out there in in san
francisco all right
i'm gonna go with todd bowles i mean
just off of that i mean todd bowles
way to freaking go unsung hero what he
did
he broke out of the mold of being todd
bowles to win a super bowl
i mean that's what i think is amazing
and you know to add to that
by everything i see when i watch the
game back on film and all that
andy reid and eric vienneme didn't think
he was going to break out of that mold
they called plays like they thought it
was going to be the same old todd bowles
hill blitz he can't help it that's what
he does
let's torch that again oh guess what
todd bowles
self-scouted thyself and said not this
week son
and he gets it done and was awesome i
mean just awesome with the disguises the
different coverages
just a few blitzes five of them the
whole game
but just at the right time and crazy
enough to where
my homes couldn't figure out what it was
exactly that was coming so way to go
todd bowles
i'm staying on the same side of the ball
same position
that i selected earlier levante david
the guy who's just become
forgotten he's the guy who was there he
predates
everyone he was drafted in 2012 think of
all the crap he's been through
and to team up with devon white
neutralize travis kelsey
relatively speaking i know still 133
receiving yards but a lot of that came
after
it was uh well into garbage time or what
should have been regarded in hindsight
is garbage time
but lavonte david teaming up with devon
white and providing that that strong
presence you know we talk about
the defensive line and how important it
is to getting to the quarterback in the
back end how important it is to keeping
receivers covered
a lot of times you take for granted you
just gloss over the guys in that middle
level
and for the buccaneers white and david
without them they don't win that game
yeah no no doubt about it i like it and
i mean they're phenomenal you're right
they play the defense to put pressure on
them and they got it done
all right my next one uh i'm gonna go
with the bucks uh the tackles the
offensive tackles i mean i want to go
with the whole offensive line
but man donovan smith tristan worth you
mentioned him earlier in the show
i mean they were just phenomenal all
year we didn't hear frank clark's name
called on super bowl sunday he's one of
the better pass rushers the
ends in football he was not even on the
telecast
that's because of those guys they were
amazing all game long
they got to get some credit vida veya is
my last one a guy who we were stunned
when he was brought back to the roster
from injury preserve before the nfc
championship game
he was great he was awesome not that the
chiefs really tried to run
but part of that wall that was putting
constant pressure on patrick mahomes
not that he could track him down there
was one play where you could see him
kind of chugging
after patrick holmes and it's just like
he ran out of gas in an
instant but hey he's a big guy and he
hasn't played a lot but he did
a lot in the middle of that defensive
line and yeah
uh yeah so he gets he gets a little
praise i got you yeah pete wants me to
go with carlton davis carlton davis was
very good but it was a lot of zone and
safety help pete so i can't go with him
there i'm gonna go with sue
the guy who actually led the game in sax
he had one and a half sacks in the damn
game he was really good
you know oh wait and here's another odd
thing about the game but just the
referees
sue threw a right hook and punched
mahomes in the head and it didn't get
called
you know again they beat the crap out of
him but it was blatant he punched him in
the head and it didn't get caught
mahomes said
he punched me in the head weird but sue
was dominant a physical presence all
playoffs all season long way to go and
dama consu
sue has perfected the art of of
giving guys the business in a way that
it's not immediately obvious he's given
them the business he's been doing that
for a long time but hey that's what
football is sometimes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc
sports